[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Marvel Avengers video
for the secret projects that Marvel has
had going on in the background in the
movies
several Easter eggs and deleted scenes
that have shown that they've been
setting up Wolverine in the x-men this
whole time this video is mostly going to
be about Wolverine but it also kind of
applies to a lot of the Fox characters
which also include the Fantastic Four
but we'll just be covering the
Wolverines stub so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Wolverine Easter egg in the comments
below we'll just do this top 5 style so
last summer comic-con Marvel revealed
that they had plans for a new x-men
movie within the MCU new Fantastic Four
new Deadpool 3 movie obviously because
right before Avengers end game was
released in theaters the Fox Disney deal
closed and they got the rights back to
all those characters mutants and x-men
are either changeable I just said I just
said mutants but yes whatever we do will
be quite different than what's been done
with Kevin Feige said that his new
version of the characters would be very
different from what we had seen before
in all the Fox x-men movies that was
mostly lead that he would be recasting
most of them but for the most part Hugh
Jackman said he's retired so when we're
talking about Wolverine Easter eggs here
setting up a new version of Wolverine it
will be a new actor that plays the
character but because up to that point
at Comic Con last summer most fans had
assumed that because they hadn't been
allowed to use those characters in MCU
movies before that point we just start
seeing Easter eggs for all the new
versions of x-men characters and
Wolverine during the Marvel phase for
movies then at some point most people
just assume that they would show up
during Marvel phase 5 but here's the
thing Marvel has been setting up mutants
and x-men in the MCU since the very
beginning of Marvel phase 1 their very
first movies that they ever released so
some of these scenes will apply to all
the Fox x-men characters but we'll just
be talking about Wolverine in this video
number 4 Wolverines code name in the
comics is Weapon X but Weapon X is
actually the designation of the program
that the US military used to create him
the Weapon X program is a subset of the
weapons Plus program Wolverines program
is actually called Weapon 10 because
Wolverine was the 10th person that they
experimented on in the weapons Plus
program
just for reference Captain America was
designation weapon one so the
super-soldier program is the weapons
plus program they didn't start calling
it the weapons plus program til
Thunderbolt Ross took over the program
and dusted it off which I'll talk about
in a second but it's always been the
super-soldier program is just that in
each different iteration of the weapons
Plus program weapon 1 weapon 2 up to
weapon 10 with Wolverine they just try
something very different to enhance
soldiers so number 3 during the
Incredible Hulk there's a special scene
where Thunderbolt Ross explains how he
dusted off the super soldier program and
has them doing new different things with
it good work in banner was doing gamma
research for the military as a member of
that larger weapons Plus team well in
ww2 they initiated a subprogram for
biotech force enhancement super soldier
yes an oversimplification but yes
banners work was very early phase
it wasn't even weapons application he
thought he was working on radiation
resistance what the project was
even though banner didn't realize that
he was trying to help create a new Super
Soldier Serum it is the same gamma
research that caused him to become the
Hulk in the first place I love to hear
Thunderbolt Ross saying that he was
pulling a fast one on the Hulk the whole
time I would have never told banner what
he was really working on so when
Thunderbolt Ross goes to dos Emil
Blonsky with the most recent version of
the Super Soldier Serum that he's been
working on as part of this program he
opens up the tanks that looked like
they've been locked down for a long time
and it's clearly marked weapons Plus
this isn't even the first Wolverine
easter egg in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it's just the next step on
them preparing to eventually get the
Wolverine character back so that they
can introduce him through a Weapon X
storyline and this becomes a really cool
Wolverine and Hulk connection for their
backstories in the Marvel Universe for
the movies they did a version of the
Weapon X program during Wolverine
Origins showing him getting the
adamantium bonded to his skeleton they
kind of did a rebooted version of that
during x-men apocalypse too with
Wolverine in the middle of escaping the
facility like he did in the comics with
that big headset
that's meant to be right after he has
the adamantium bonded to his skeleton
the whole mr. sinister post-credit scene
isn't something from the comics that's
just something that they did for a movie
that will never wind up happening
because it was part of the old Fox plans
for those characters Marvel has
different better plans the reason why
it's important that Marvel was using the
Incredible Hulk movie during phase 1 to
establish the full scope of the weapons
Plus program and said all that Weapon X
step up is because Wolverines very first
appearance ever was in the Incredible
Hulk comic book he appeared out of the
shadows at the very end of Incredible
Hulk number 180 then in the next issue
Incredible Hulk number 181 they had
their first big Hulk vs. Wolverine fight
and they went on to have many many
rematches over the years but making
banner a big part of the weapons Plus
program that early on was all about
setting up an eventual Wolverine Hulk
connection in future Marvel movies once
Marvel eventually got the rights to him
in the MCU the funny thing though is
that because this was happening so many
years ago back in 2008 when they were
writing this script even before that it
was still Hugh Jackman that was playing
Wolverine
so when Kevin Feige was picturing Hulk
vs. Wolverine in the MCU Marvel movie at
this point in time it would have still
been Edward Norton's Hulk vs. Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine but just because
those actors have been recast already in
the case of Edward Norton and eventually
recasting a new Wolverine doesn't mean
Marvel is gonna retcon all this weapons
Plus Weapon X Thunderbolt raw stuff that
they were setting up way back in Marvel
phase 1 because number 2 jumped to
present day in Marvel phase 4 after
avengers endgame there was new Falcon
and Winter Soldier footage screened
recently just before everyone in
Hollywood went on lockdown and one of
the scenes from an early episode
featured Winter Soldier going to visit
Baron Zemo in his special prison during
the scene Baron Zemo tries and fails to
reactivate winter soldiers Hydra
programming that he learned from that
red book the reason it doesn't work is
because sure he already deprogrammed him
before Avengers infinity war so the
commands don't trigger him anymore but
after they have that funny awkward
moment Winter Soldier walks up to Baron
Zemo and tells him that Thunderbolt Ross
has restarted the super soldier weapons
Plus program so now you see Marvel gets
the rights back to the Wolverine
character in just coincidentally 12
years later they finally start to
pay off the weapons plus Incredible Hulk
Easter eggs there are a couple reasons
why they're doing weapons plus story on
Falcon and Winter Soldier one to show
more backstory for the programs through
the other lesser-known participants like
Isaiah Bradley if you're not a big
Captain America comic book reader he's
the person that they tested the Super
Soldier Serum on before they gave it to
Captain America so he's sort of like the
prototype for Captain America and then
the second reason is obviously in
present day as it's implied Captain
America John Walker aka u.s. agent seems
like he gets a new version of the Super
Soldier Serum look at him in this
picture here from the set he's got one
of his arms hurt he looks kind of small
then in the next picture when he's got
the Captain America suit on he looks
jacked up Captain America effectively
retired when he came back a super old
man so the government just selects their
own Captain America and then mints him
by giving him that new Super Soldier
Serum I don't know what they're doing
with this version of the shield I don't
know if they take it back from Falcon
because we see Falcon playing with it
during the trailer but number one final
big piece of evidence that they've been
planning this whole mutants Weapon X
backstory literally since the very
beginning of the MCU is during the first
Ironman post-credit scene from the first
Iron Man movie there's an alternate
version of this scene that they wrote
for the movie and filmed where Nick Fury
comes to tell Iron Man about the
Avengers but also talks about mutants
and Spider Man I have to deal with a
spoiled brat who doesn't play well with
others and wants to keep all his toys to
himself when Nick Fury references
mutants Kevin Feige and Marvel were
using that as a catch-all term for all
of the Fox x-men characters the reason
why they couldn't actually leave that in
the movie is because only Fox was
allowed to use the term mutants per the
contract with Marvel for those
characters but you can hear how they
tried to step around the issue of not
being able to use spider-man yet by
saying radioactive spiders but that's
them referencing the Tobey Maguire
spider-man because when they filmed this
it was still 2007 they didn't release
the movie till 2008 that next year so
Tobey Maguire was still spider-man Hugh
Jackman was still Wolverine they were
getting ready to release Wolverine
Origins
me don't scratch just clean it up the
timelines so clearly it seems like Kevin
Feige
early attempts to share the characters
to get Wolverine in the MCU were
unsuccessful and now he can just finally
do it 12 years later paying this all off
but it's just really cool to see all the
times that Marvel has been trying to set
up Weapon X and Wolverine inside the MCU
without actually having access to the
character but let me know if you think
that the new version of Wolverine should
debut in a Weapon X movie and they
should make it a big Hulk crossover like
thor ragnarok but everyone post your
theories in the comments below there'll
be a bunch of Marvel stuff coming up
there'll be more Marvel phase 4 trailer
soon - congratulations Marty Bruce
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page my channel so I can get your
details
everyone click here for my big Marvel
phase 4 trailer video and click here for
that brand new Fantastic Four movie
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]